[Música]
i
hola bienvenidos a francia enfoco
nuestra mirada a la actualidad francesa
hoy veremos por qué los estudiantes de
francia tienen el nivel de conocimientos
de matemática más bajo de toda europa
iremos hasta la isla de córcega la
llamada fábrica de campeones de ajedrez
allí conoceremos porque tiene bien
ganado ese apelativo y terminaremos en
la ciudad luz con un vistazo a una
minuciosa labor que pretende devolver su
esplendor a los vitrales de la catedral
de notre-dame acompáñanos
aquí
[Música]
múltiples estudios demuestran que los
estudiantes franceses no están
aprendiendo matemáticas tan bien como
antes de hecho francia ocupa el último
lugar en una reciente investigación que
midió el nivel de matemáticas de más de
medio millón de estudiantes europeos
esto se debe en parte a una reforma
educativa de 2019 que eliminó esa
disciplina de la parrilla de asignaturas
obligatorias en las escuelas secundarias
como consecuencia en el último año de
ese nivel de enseñanza cerca de 40 por
ciento de los estudiantes no tomó ni una
sola clase de matemáticas en europa el
peor puesto en matemáticas y se lo lleva
francia sentado en una esquina al fondo
de la clase el país galo es el mal
alumno de la unión europea según la
última encuesta sobre tendencias en los
estudios de matemáticas y ciencias
realizada en 2019 empatado con rumanía
en la unión europea francia también es
el penúltimo entre los 38 países de la
ocde sólo por delante de chile según el
informe teams los alumnos actuales de
octavo grado tienen el mismo nivel que
tenían los de séptimo grado en
1995 en cuanto a los alumnos de quinto
de primaria
7 a veces divisiones frente al 74 de
1987 y esta tendencia no es nueva según
un informe gubernamental de marzo de
2021 el nivel medio de conocimientos
matemáticos en francia ha ido
descendiendo desde hace casi 40 años la
reforma del bachillerato y de las
pruebas del final de la educación
secundaria superior ha acelerado la
tendencia al eliminar las matemáticas de
las asignaturas comunes de grado 11
ahora sólo el 59% de los alumnos del
último curso de bachillerato siguen
estudiando matemáticas 30 el 90% de
antes de 2019 en sus competencias
también han disminuido en 1995 el 15%
alcanzaba el llamado nivel avanzado 20
años después sólo el 1% lo había hecho
entender las matemáticas complejas es
esencial para las ciencias la tecnología
y la innovación pero para los ingenieros
es imprescindible sin embargo como
veremos en el siguiente reporte al
entrar a las universidades tecnológicas
muchos estudiantes tienen serios
problemas con los números
inicial
hace un año estos alumnos pasaron el
back el examen de bachillerato francés
ahora cursan el primer año preparatorio
para la escuela de ingenieros y todavía
están poniéndose al día en algunos
conocimientos matemáticos
y yo necesariamente todos los
estudiantes han visto todas las nociones
que son fundamentales para cualquier
rama de la ingeniería como por ejemplo
los números complejos que en física son
nociones indispensables para estos
futuros ingenieros no cabe duda la
reforma del back implementada hace dos
años está responsable de sus lagunas en
algunas naciones la mayoría sólo cruzó
el núcleo común de matemáticas en su
último año escolar y no la opción con
tres horas adicionales y un programa
mucho más complejo yo no tenía ninguna
base en particular sobre las ecuaciones
diferenciales y los números complejos
porque eran cosas que no había visto si
es cierto que al llegar aquí
definitivamente el nivel es más alto
para alguien que no hizo la especialidad
en matemáticas metí expect después de la
reforma del back pero también tras dos
años de pandemia la escuela de
ingenieros estableció un examen de
admisión con el objetivo de evaluar el
nivel de cada alumno y determinar en qué
debe ponerse al día de esta manera todos
tendrán la posibilidad de orientarse
profesionalmente elemento de éxito las
matemáticas son una de muchas
herramientas para forjar un espíritu
permiten tener buenas habilidades para
después estar en una situación adecuada
a la empresa y para el mundo ciudadano
en general
el mundo empresarial ha sido el primero
en abogar porque las matemáticas vuelvan
a ocupar un lugar central en educación
secundaria pero antes de la elección
presidencial 30 directivos del índice
bursátil francés cac-40 firmaron un
artículo de opinión en el que pedían
salvar las matemáticas todo comenzó con
la evidencia de la escasez de ingenieros
en francia 20 mil al año según la
organización profesional de ingeniería
solís héctor afecto hay una
escasez en todos los sectores la
economía francesa se está digitalizando
progresivamente y para eso se necesitan
habilidades informáticas y sites de
competencia forma ética a la
digitalización de la economía se suma la
fuga de cerebros científicos hacia
países con mejores salarios o hacia el
sector financiero por el momento se
vislumbra una solución a esta
deficiencia del sistema educativo
francés las matemáticas regresarán a los
liceos del país como asignatura
obligatoria
nos vamos a córcega una isla francesa
conocida por sus playas y su gastronomía
pero ahora hablamos de otra de sus
especialidades el ajedrez es que esa
tradición se enseña allí desde los
primeros años de vida y de hecho es una
asignatura obligatoria en la enseñanza
primaria còrsega es conocida como la
fábrica de campeones de ajedrez
bajo el sol de córcega el ajedrez
encontró una tierra predilecta y la isla
tiene ahora un campeón de gran talante
marc andré a morirse
hace un año este colegial obtuvo el
reconocimiento más importante el título
de gran maestro internacional
convirtiéndose con 14 años y cinco días
en el francés más joven en obtener este
galardón
es el título más alto y es verdad que es
un buen nivel creo que es el gran
maestro es como firmar un contrato
profesional con un club del fútbol como
el marsella y el parís wat bus y
aunque juega ajedrez con la cabeza como
todo gran campeón también debe cuidar su
cuerpo con su entrenador cada semana
hace un entrenamiento intensivo
es un gran maestro sí pero sobre todo es
un niño esto le permite relajar el
cerebro y tener más capacidad para
aguantar largas partidas de ajedrez en
las que a veces hay que estar seis u
ocho horas sentado frente al adversario
largas partidas que juega una tabla de
otra y además gana su última victoria
fue en el campeonato de francia por
equipos ahora regresa coronado con su
título al club que lo vio debutar
el primero en haber descubierto al
futuro campeón fue acá bill es ajeno el
presidente de la liga course a su mamá
pero es ciudad y típico recuerdo que el
primero de primaria todavía era un niño
pero ya era bueno y aunque era mucho
mejor que sus compañeros de clase cuando
hacíamos un torneo les hacía jugar les
explicaba tenía una cierta bondad y
jones una actitud que se cultiva en este
club de ajedrez en el centro de bastia y
que cuenta con varios seguidores todos
los días después del colegio una centena
de niños vienen a enfrentarse delante de
un tablero de ajedrez pero hoy marca
andrea es la atracción del lugar
el
adversario del día a polo de 12 años no
pudo contra él
pero apoyo no tiene nada de qué
avergonzarse es campeón de colegios de
francia lo que estos pequeños prodigios
tienen en común la que es nuestra efe es
que todos empezaron a jugar ajedrez en
el colegio en córcega desde hace 25 años
es una asignatura obligatoria como las
matemáticas o el francés nos volvemos a
encontrar con acav y les hago esta vez
como profesor la edad físico ua equipo
de tonghua
el ajedrez tiene virtudes pedagógicas
ejercita la lógica y la concentración y
desde aquí por ejemplo la tranquilidad
que hay aprender a estar tranquilos a
pensar a respetar las reglas
expectorante hacemos esto está solo eso
ya es un gran triunfo los alumnos no se
perderían la clase por nada del mundo
es que vamos a saber
en 25 años 50.000 alumnos han asistido a
estas clases córcega ahora tiene un gran
maestro internacional pero también 13
campeones de francia y 2 campeones de
europa una gran victoria para el ajedrez
nos adentramos ahora en la
reconstrucción de uno de los símbolos de
la capital francesa la catedral de
notre-dame durante su incendio en 2019
se perdió gran parte de su estructura
pero los vitrales resistieron hoy un
equipo de expertos trabaja para retirar
el hollín que los cubre y devolverles su
esplendor
en estos andamios de hierro se lleva a
cabo una de las operaciones más
minuciosas de la reconstrucción de
notredame el desmontaje y limpieza de
los vitrales en esta primera etapa de
las obras al interior de la catedral los
restauradores están obligados a usar
escafandras para protegerse del polvo de
plomo
y
el incendio de hace más de tres años
puso en peligro todo el edificio algunas
de sus estructuras se abrieron a más de
1000 grados celsius sin embargo ninguno
de los vitrales fue destruido por las
llamas
además de las sustancias generadas por
el incendio los vitrales han acumulado
el link que crean las velas encendidas
su última limpieza se llevó a cabo en
1880 en esta ocasión también ha sido
necesario fijar algunas piezas
en esas partes debilitadas en piezas
desajustadas que podrían caerse y
dañarse por eso hicimos una especie de
pre fijación temporal para la etapa de
desmontaje eso evita que se desprendan
en el traslado los paneles de vidrio son
enviados a 8 talleres de restauración en
francia uno de ellos está en tu a a unos
180 kilómetros al este de parís
aquí los maestros vidrieros han recibido
un vitral de 6 metros de largo
la muy bella
aquí se ve un gran personaje frente a
una arquitectura con un borde decorativo
de follaje de fallas su única arma para
limpiar los vitrales un hisopo agua y un
poco de alcohol ha dicho q tú con este
algodón fue también la superficie
retiramos el hollín y poco a poco vamos
viendo los vitrales y así en ese velo
negro así que no hay nada realmente
complicado memo concluye a este
minucioso trabajo que durarán meses se
añade el reforzamiento de las juntas de
plomo con la fecha de reapertura de
notredame prevista para 2024 no hay
tiempo que perder
los rangers tenemos que ganar esta
batalla para el 2024 y les puedo decir
que en el sitio todos están movilizados
para ello hice la acción
un centenar de vitrales volverá a unirse
para que una luz única de su lumbre
nuevamente en la catedral de notre-dame
y hasta aquí esta emisión de francia en
foco no se encuentra cada semana en la
señal de televisión france24 y en
nuestras redes sociales hasta la próxima